[Music]
and reddit diagnosis good news thank you
I graduated high school submitted by
[Laughter]
graduate high school then she started
town in an hour
hey you'd like a look at these before I
read them but like you know this is new
for me I didn't know if you were kidding
or not I wasn't on that okay cuz it was
really fun and gets it sounded stupid
okay anyway mmm I mean I like
Shakespeare at this [ __ ] out people are
posting their genitals on reddit to
diagnose Esther days
oh no yeah um it doesn't matter how you
say STD it never sounds good I don't
care what accent you have didn't they
change it to STI yeah but people still
call it it because of the stigma yeah
yeah it's like you know WWE WWF what's
really the difference I know right well
I guess infection is more accurate than
disease that's why I tried to change it
to STI really you're just causing more
confusion and paranoia and the patient
feel like you know that's how I feel
watching Toby Toby I feel like watching
you oh I agree with you what ship were
you really yeah I was Jenna I never know
it you two you drive me crazy oh yeah
and you are so sweet
what the [ __ ] and you tolerate me all
right so anyway anyway so people have
been posting photos of their genitalia
honest on reddit to see if read it
people can diagnose for them these STDs
so there's the subreddit dr. forum be
honest was it you know doctors no but
like where are you helping to diagnose
these people are like what karna goes in
the story were you involved in nah
I'm telling she's wondering how you
found the article yeah on me I wrote the
article mmm who's doing this be a good
story yeah she writes all the articles
show one submitted it baby said their
name I know what was her name this is my
own did get checked okay yeah I get
check okay so alright so anyway so then
they're saying that rates of syphilis
gonorrhea and chlamydia have hit an
all-time high
back in 2018 and so because of that
doctors worry that there may be a lot of
patients out there that are either
receiving that are not receiving proper
treatments or you know like they don't
even know that they need to go get help
or like you know seek treatment so
frustrating they're saying that shame or
lack of access means many are missing an
opportunity to get professional
life-saving health and so a lot of
people turn to reddit under the
subreddit STD which has more than 10,000
members including some certified
physicians and so apparently a total of
sixteen thousand nine hundred and
seventy nine threads happened between
November 2010 through February of this
year and between November of 2010 and
December there were only eight post oops
and then so November and December of
2018 there were close to 850 posts so
the trend has okay but here's the thing
it's like why would a doctor be just
doing that for funsies in his off time
just like or she like but how do you
know who's trolling and because there's
some creative writers there that are
like I'm a doctor I went to this school
I've done this for this year in many
years and I can tell you 100% that is
blank you know who is trolling and he
was a really doctor cuz if I was
doctoring all freaking day and they have
long shifts I wouldn't go home and be
like who can i diagnose now they already
hate it yeah I think it's the ones that
offer to transfer you like eighty five
million dollars and you know a chance
for you to make a hundred I think that's
kind of when you know that maybe this
isn't legit that could be yeah cuz
they'll be honest like to [ __ ] with
people they do and I think what's really
the big problem here is that people
think just because they take perhaps
that's probably gonna [ __ ]
ruin your kidneys and you'll die from
that anyway prep is a the drug that you
take to not get HIV to prevent you to
get HIV so basically what it does is
like it destroys your internal organs so
you don't catch the virus if you've
taken it at the right time before you
like you know contracted it or you're
supposed to take it when you know you're
supposed to [ __ ] someone with AIDS
okay I'm when the [ __ ] got the HIV or
whatever girl I'm gonna take this first
it'll make me immune but my kidneys are
exploding it's not like Plan B the
reason I said like that is because
syphilis syphilis is like it's actually
quite scary like you can have permanent
brain damage if you don't get the right
treatment for your nurse you know or
like you went to right I worked in a
hospital by like patients I didn't know
that until you didn't save me from the
fly but tried to save me from the fly
and that was really nice of you oh thank
you had great reflexes if I never seen
you in a video before I would think that
you're insane for what you just said
saving for saving me from the fly yeah
the fly it was that assaulted me but
without context nobody knows I was
assaulted by a fly okay and I haven't
forgot about it and I am so grateful
that I decided to overcome my fear and
show up today
why don't you smack it with the fly
swatters you know your big hands are you
trying hands stop signs
please don't conscience over look at my
hand again you look good we have like
the same size hands are crazy we should
have something to scale though we need
something to scale because I don't think
okay so anyway my point was y'all go get
yourself checked and [ __ ] okay no but
thrilled like it's a big deal that
syphilis is a big deal I don't think
people are contracting that because they
think just cuz they're taking prep that
they're not gonna get anything like
that's for HIV you can still get
hepatitis herpes syphilis there's so
much other stuff you could get so is
this article saying like
is kind of like a cool space right now
for people that would otherwise not seek
treatment because they're embarrassed
brought it back to the right place I
think so
yeah so they're just saying like you
know they're just pointing out the fact
that now it seems like there's so many
people that would prefer or maybe have
to turn to the internet to look at for
them to diagnose [ __ ] that's on their
genitals cuz there would be like post
like what's what's wrong with my penis
or wipe thing on inside of or skin or
anyone think this looks like HPV so
there's just all these posts happening
and I mean like they did mention that
there are physicians on reddit so I
don't know dude this is a good
opportunity for any entrepreneurs out
there to [ __ ] create an app where
people can [ __ ] jump on this [ __ ]
yeah money they put some vetted doctors
or medical profession yeah and then they
just bridge it and now people can do it
you know it is important because they
are saying that social media was not
built to deliver health care so there's
a lot of health issues that cannot be
accurately diagnosed just through a
photo or through a video like you really
need to go in person and maybe take like
samples and let a blogger needs to see
you why a psychologist can look at just
a picture of you like if I took
appreciate you said right now and I put
it on one of those websites they would
be able to diagnose you very accurate
what would they say how many things
assume that I have a awesome personality
it's a list it takes a lotta long wave I
say personalities would it still be that
yes yeah it would be minute you can't
say a or an you know it don't disrupt
the dyslexic okay no you're fine thank
you
dyslexic I am Oh have you seen my
captions on my [ __ ] Instagram have
you seen them okay there's I'm not
dyslexic and I'm sure mine are just as
[ __ ] up you know every time I read a
car DB post though I feel so much better
about myself
he's like first of all I love her but
then I like read like [ __ ] okay I'm not
I'm doing pretty good
yes
can you hold this real quick
Syd is holding a giant bottle of Tapatio
right it's a gallon that is a huge that
is a two gallon er just to give you know
that just shows you that just gives you
an idea out there just from those
fingers you guys remember that from
bring it on it's not gonna be a sponsor
now because I can't you can't keep big
fingers crossed
[Laughter]
can we get a doctor to diagnose looks
like just let it snow let it snow
I'm so glad we had us talk about sti's I
mean well you know whatever you want to
call it they use SC's easier yeah no but
I don't know man I mean I get this those
like young kids in high school they're
all [ __ ] like craters yeah we're all
scared to go to their parents to tell
them hey I got I think I got some [ __ ]
so they're going on reddit that's what
Planned Parenthood's for true
it's just dated to go back to what
you're saying with a D it is always the
D it's never I hey hey that was a late
it was late does Lee yeah I want you to
step off the stage you can't go back on
and ask for the callback you can if you
don't remember that you were there in
the first place
oh that's pretty good thank you what
it's never me I thought you're thinking
about my wig okay I asked for the
callback you tagged that [ __ ]
can we can we butcher this some more
please it's not us you know it's really
bothering my cat ears are bothering me
so bad
Oh take her I don't want to be the ghost
of the look you know are you worried
that you might be inconsistent no I just
they hurt moving to y'all because I am
channeling my it's it's a long story
it's your brand [ __ ] are you yes that's
the one you guys go check it out get
your Yanni egg and let all my